the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so professor jerison is relaxing in
sunny London Ontario today and sent me
and his his substitute again I'm glad to
be here and see you all again
so our agenda today he said that he'd
already talked about power series and
Taylor's formula I guess on last week
right on Friday and so I'm going to go a
little further with that show you some
examples show you some applications and
then I have this course evaluation
survey that I'll hand out in in the last
10 minutes or so of the class I also
have this handout that he made that says
1801 end of term 2007 if you didn't pick
this up coming in grab it going out
people tend not to pick it up when they
walk in I see so grab this one you're
going out there's some things missing
from it he has not decided when his hour
his office hours will be at the end of
term he will have them he just hasn't
decided when so check the website for
that information and we're looking
forward to the final exam which is
aren't we any questions about this
technical stuff all right let's talk
about power series for a little bit so I
thought I should review for you what the
story with power series is
okay could I have your attention please
so a power series is a is a way of
writing a function as a sum of integral
powers of X these a 0 a 1 and so on are
numbers an example of a power series is
a polynomial not to be forgotten one
type of power series is one which goes
on for a finite number of terms and then
ends so that all of the other all the
higher a sub i's are all 0 this is a
perfectly good example of a power series
it's a very special kind of power series
and part of what I want to tell you
today is that power series behave almost
exactly like polynomials there's just
one thing that you have to be careful
about when you're using power series
that doesn't isn't a concern for
polynomials and I'll show you what that
is in a minute so you should think of
them as generalised polynomials the one
thing that you have to be careful about
is that this there is a number so one
caution there's a number which I'll call
R where R can be between 0 and and it
can also be infinity it's a number
between 0 and infinity inclusive so that
when the absolute value of x is less
than R so when X is smaller than R in
size the sum converges
this Sun that Sun converges to a finite
value and when X is bigger than R in
absolute value the sum diverges this R
is called the radius of convergence so
we'll see some examples of what the
radius of convergence is in various
power series as well and how you find it
also but let me go on and give you a few
more of the properties about power
series which I think that professor
jerison talked about earlier so one of
them is there's a radius of convergence
here's another another one if you're
inside of the radius of convergence then
the function has all its derivatives has
all its derivatives
just like a polynomial does you can
differentiate it over and over again
and in terms of those derivatives the
number a sub n in in the power series
can be expressed in terms of the value
of the derivative at zero and this is
called Taylor's formula so I'm saying
that inside of this radius of
convergence the function that we're
looking at this f of X can be written as
the value of the function at zero that's
a sub zero plus the derivative the value
of the derivative this bracket n means
you take the derivative end times so
when n is 1 you take the derivative once
at 0 divided by 1 factorial which is 1
and multiply it by X that's the linear
term in the power series and then the
quadratic term is you take the second
derivative remember to divide by 2
factorial which is 2 multiply that by x
squared and so on out so in terms so the
the coefficients in the power series
just record the values of the
derivatives of the function at x equals
0 and they can be computed that way also
let's see I think those that's a end of
my summary of things that he talked
about I think he did one example and
I'll repeat that example of a power
series this example wasn't due to David
garrison it was due to Leonard Euler and
it's the example of where the function
is the exponential function e to the X
so let's see let's compute what I will
just repeat for you the computation of
the power series for e to the X just
because it's such an important thing to
do so in order to do that I have to know
what the derivative of e to the X is and
what the second derivative of e to the X
is and so on because that comes into the
Taylor formula for the for the
coefficients but we know what the
derivative of e to
X is it's just e to the X again and it's
that way all the way down all the
derivatives are e to the x over and over
again so when I evaluate this at x
equals 0
well the value of e to the X is 1 the
value of e to the X is 1 and x equals 0
you get a value of 1 all the way down so
all these derivatives at 0 have the
value 1 and now when I plug into this
formula I find e to the X is 1 plus 1
times X plus 1 over 2 factorial times x
squared plus 1 over 3 factorial times X
cubed plus and so on so all of these
numbers are 1 and all you wind up with
is the factorials in the denominators
that's the power series for e to the X
this was a discovery of Leonhard Euler
in 1740 or something yes ma'am how far
do you have to write the power series
before it becomes well-defined before
it's a satisfactory solution to an exam
problem I suppose is another way to
phrase the question until it's until you
can see what the pattern is I can see
what the pattern is is there anyone
who's in doubt about what the next term
might be some people would tell you that
you have to write the summation
convention thing don't believe them if
you write out enough terms to make it
clear that's good enough ok inside of an
answer for you ok so that's the that's a
basic example let's do another basic
example of a power suits oh yes and by
the way whenever you write out a power
series you can say what the radius of
convergence is and for now I will just
tell you that the radius of convergence
of this power series is infinity that is
this sum always converges for any value
of x and I'll say a little more about
that in a few minutes
yeah
which functions can be written as power
series that's an excellent question any
function that has a reasonable
expression can be written as power
series I'm not giving you a very good
answer because the true answer is a
little bit complicated but any of the
functions that occur in calculus like
sines and cosines tangents they all have
a power series expansions okay we'll see
more examples let's do another example
here's another example I guess this was
example one so this example I think was
due to Newton not Euler let's find the
power series expansion of this function
1 over 1 plus X well I think that
somewhere along the line you learned
about the geometric series which tells
you that which tells you what the answer
to this is and I'll just write it out
the geometric series tells you that this
function can be written as an
alternating sum of powers of X you may
wonder where these minuses came from
well if you really about the geometric
series as you probably remember there
was a minus sign here and that gets
replaced by these minus signs I think
maybe jerison talked about this also
anyway here's another basic example
remember what the graph of this function
looks like when X is equal to minus 1
then there's a little problem here
because the denominator becomes 0 so the
graph has a pole there goes up to
infinity at x equals minus 1 and that's
an indication that the radius of
convergence doesn't is not infinity
because if you try to converge to this
infinite number by putting in x equals
minus 1 here you'll have a big problem
in fact you see when you put in X equals
minus 1 you keep getting 1 in every term
and it gets bigger and bigger and does
not converge in this example the radius
of convergence is 1 okay so let's do a
new example now oh and by the way I
should say you can calculate these
numbers using Taylor's formula if you
haven't seen it check it out
calculate the iterated derivatives of
this function and plug in x equals 0 and
see that you get plus 1 minus 1 plus 1
minus 1 and so on yes sir I see that if
you do minus 1 it'll blow up if you put
in 1 though it seems like it would be
fine question is I can see that there's
a problem at x equals minus 1 why is
there also a problem at x equals 1 where
the graph is perfectly smooth and
innocuous and finite that's another
excellent question the problem is that
if you go off to a radius of 1 in any
direction and there's a problem that's
it that's what the radius of convergence
is here what what does happen if I put
in x equals plus 1 so let's look at the
partial sums so it and x equals plus 1
in your mind here so I'll get the
partial sum 1 and then 0 and then 1 and
then 0 and then 1 so even though it
doesn't blow up to infinity it still
does not converge and any of these other
things will also fail to converge in
this example well that's the only two
real numbers that the edge right ok
let's do a different example now how
about a trig function let's sine of X
I'm going to compute the power series
expansion for the sine of X and I'm
going to do it using Taylor's formula so
Taylor's formula says that I have to
start computing derivatives of the sine
of X
and it sounds like it's going to be a
lot of work let's see the derivative of
the sine is the cosine and the
derivative of the cosine that's the
second derivative of sine is what
remember the - it's minus sine of X okay
now I want to take the third derivative
of the sine which is the derivative of
sine prime prime so it's the derivative
of this and we just decided the
derivative of sine is cosine so I get
cosine but I have this minus sign in
front and now I want to differentiate
again
so the cosine becomes a minus sign and
that minus sign cancels with this minus
sign to give me sine of X you follow
that a lot of minus ones cancelling out
there so all of a sudden I'm right back
where I started these two are the same
and the pattern will now repeat forever
and ever higher and higher derivatives
of signs are just plus or minus signs
and co-signs now if the Taylor's
Taylor's formula says I should now
substitute x equals zero into this and
see what happens so let's do that when X
is equal to zero the sine is zero the
cosine is one the sine is zero so minus
0 is also zero the cosine is one but now
there's a minus one and now I'm back
where I started and so the pattern will
repeat ok so the values of the
derivatives are all zeros and plus and
minus ones and they go through that
pattern fourfold periodicity over and
over again and so we can write out what
the sine of X is using Taylor's formula
using this formula so I put in the value
it's zero which is zero then I put in
the derivative which is
one multiply it by X then I have the
second derivative divided by two
factorial but the second derivative at
zero is zero so I'm going to drop that
term out now I have the third derivative
which is minus one and remember the
three factorial in the denominator and
that's the coefficient of x cubed what's
the fourth derivative well here we are
it's on the board at zero so I dropped
that term out go up to the fifth term
the fifth power of X its derivative is
now one we've gone through the pattern
we're back at plus one as the value of
the iterated derivative so now I get one
over five factorial times X to the fifth
and now you tell me have we done enough
terms to see what the pattern is I guess
the next term will be a minus 1 over 7
factorial X to the seventh and so on let
me write this out again it's just so we
have X cubed over 3 factorial so it's X
minus X cubed over 3 factorial plus X to
the fifth over 5 factorial you guessed
it and so on that's the power series
expansion for the sine of X okay and so
the signs alternate and these
denominators get very big don't they how
Exponential's grow very fast let me make
a remark R is infinity here the radius
of convergence of this power series
again is infinity and let me just say
why the reason is that the term X to the
well then the general term is going to
be like X to the 2n plus 1 divided by 2
SN plus 1 factorial an odd number I can
write as 2n plus 1
and what I want to say is that the size
of this what happens to the size of this
as X as n goes to infinity
so let's just think about this for a
fixed X let's fix a number X look at
powers of X and think about the size of
this expression when n gets to be large
so let's just do that for a second so X
to the 2n plus 1 over 2n plus 1
factorial I can write out like this it's
x over 1 times x over 2 times X sorry
times X over 3 x times X over 2 n plus 1
I've multiplied X by itself 2n plus 1
times in the numerator and I've
multiplied the numbers 1 2 3 4 and so on
by each other in the denominator and
that gives me the factorial so I've just
written this out like this now X is
fixed so maybe it's a million okay big
but fixed what happens to these numbers
well at first they're pretty big this is
a million over 2 this is a million over
3 but when n gets to be maybe if what is
if n is a million then this is about one
half if n is a billion then this is
about 1 over two thousand right the
denominators keep getting bigger and
bigger
but the numerators stay the same they're
always always X so when I take the
product if I go far enough out I'm going
to be multiplying by very very small
numbers more and more of them and so no
matter what X is these numbers will
converge to 0 they'll get smaller and
smaller as X gets to be bigger that's
the sign that X is inside of the radius
of convergence this is the sign for you
that that this series converges for that
value of X and because I could do this
for any X for any X this works
this converges to zero for any fixed X
that's what tells you that you can take
the radius of that the radius of
convergence is infinity because in the
formula in the in the fact this property
of the just that the radius of
convergence talks about if R is equal
infinity this is no condition on X every
number is less than infinity in absolute
value so if this convergence to zero of
the general term works for every X then
the radius of convergence is infinity
well that was kind of fast but I think
that you heard something about that
earlier as well anyway so we've got the
sine function a new function with its
own power series it's a way of computing
sine of X if you take enough terms
you'll get a good at good about a good
evaluation of the sine of X for any X
this tells you a lot about the function
sine of X but not everything at all for
example from this formula it's very hard
to see that the sine of X is periodic
not obvious at all somewhere hidden away
and this expression is the number pi the
half the period but that's not clear
from the power series at all so the
power series are very good for some
things but they hide other properties of
functions well so I want to spend a few
minutes telling you about how to what
you can do with a power series once you
have one to get new power series so new
power series from old
and this is also called operations on
power series so what are the things that
we can do to a power series well one of
the things you can do is multiply so for
example what if I want to compute a
power series 4x times the sine of X well
I have what a power series for the sine
of X I just did it how about a power
series for X actually I did that here 2x
the function X is a very simple
polynomial
it's the polynomial where that's 0 a 1
is 1 all the other coefficients are 0 so
X itself is a power series very simple
one and the sine of X is a power series
and what I want to encourage you to do
is treat power series just like
polynomials and multiply them together
we'll see other operations too so to
compute the power series 4x times the
sine of X I just take this one and
multiply it by X so let's see if I can
do that right it distributes through x
squared minus X to the fourth over 3
factorial plus X to the sixth over 5
factorial and so on
and again the radius of convergence is
going to be the smaller of the two radii
of convergence here so it's R equals
infinity in this case okay you can
multiply powers whose together it can be
a pain if the power series are very long
but if one of them is X it's pretty
simple okay it's one thing I can do
notice something by the way this is an
odd you know about even and odd
functions huh so sine is an odd function
X is an odd function the product of two
odd functions is an even function and
that's reflected in the fact that all
the powers that occur in the power
series are even for an odd function like
the sine
all the powers that occur or odd powers
of X that's always true okay we can
multiply I can also differentiate so
let's just do a case of that and I'll
use the process of differentiation to
find out what the power series for the
cosine of X is by writing the cosine of
X is the derivative of the sine and
differentiating term by term so I'll
take this expression for the power
series of the sine and differentiate it
turn by term and I'll get the power
series for cosine so let's see the
derivative of one of X is one now the
derivative of x cubed is 3x squared and
then there's a three factorial in the
denominator and the derivative of x to
the fifth is 5x to the fourth and
there's a five factorial in the
denominator and so on and so on and now
some cancellation happens so this is one
minus well the three cancels with the
last factor in this 3 factorial and
leaves you with two factorial and the
five cancels with the last factor in the
five factorial and leaves you with a
four factorial and a not in the
denominator and so there you go there's
the power series expansion for the
cosine it's got all even powers of X
they alternate you have factorials in
the denominator and of course you could
derive that expression by using Taylor's
formula by the same kind of calculation
we did here to taking higher and higher
derivatives of the cosine you get the
same periodic pattern of derivatives and
values of derivatives at x equals zero
but here's a cleaner way to do it
simpler way to do it because we already
knew the derivative of the sine when you
differentiate you keep the same radius
of convergence
okay so we can multiply we can different
I can add two and multiply by constant
things like that
how about integrating that's what half
this course was about isn't it
so let's integrate something so the
integration I'm going to do is this one
the integral from 0 to X of DT over 1
plus X what is that integral as a
function so when I find the
antiderivative of this I get the natural
log of 1 plus T and then when I evaluate
that at x equals 0 at x at t equals x I
get the natural log of 1 plus X and when
I evaluate the natural log at 0 I get
the natural log of 1 which is 0 so this
is what you get
ok this is really a valid by the way for
for X bigger than minus 1 but don't want
to think about this quite like this when
X is smaller than that ok now I'm going
to I'm going to try to apply power
series methods here and find use this
integral to find a power series for the
natural log and I'll do it by plugging
in to this expression what the power
series for 1 over 1 plus T was and I
know what that is because I wrote it
down on the board up here change the
variable from X 2 T there and so 1 over
1 plus T is 1 minus T plus T squared
minus T cubed and so on
so that's the thing in the inside of the
integral and now it's legal to integrate
that term by term so let's do that I'm
going to get something which I will then
evaluate it X and it's zero so when I
integrate one I get X when I integrate
tea cups I get tea I'm sorry
an integrate e T squared over two TQ t
squared gives me t cubed over three and
so on and so on and then when I put in x
equals when I put in T equals x well I
just replace all the T's by X's and when
I put in T equals zero I get zero so
this equals x so I'm I've discovered
that the natural log of 1 plus X is X
minus x squared over 2 plus X cubed over
3 minus X to the fourth over 4 and so on
and so on
there's the power series expansion for
the natural log of 1 plus X and because
I began with a power series whose radius
of convergence was just 1 I began with
this power series the radius of
convergence of this is also going to be
1 also because this this function is I
just pointed out this function goes bad
when X becomes less than minus 1 so some
problem happens and that's reflected in
the radius of convergence cool so so you
can integrate that is the correct power
series expansion for the natural log of
X and another victory of oil errs was to
use this kind of power series expansion
to calculate natural logarithms in a
much more efficient way than people have
done before ok
let's one more property thank where what
are we at here three four substitute
very appropriate for me as a substitute
teacher to tell you about substitution
so I'm going to try to find the power
series expansion of e to the minus T
squared okay and the way I'll do that is
by taking the power series expansion for
e to the T which we have e to the X
which we have up there and make the
substitution x equals minus T squared in
the in the expansion for e to the X do
you have a question well it was just
concerning this radius of convergence
you can't define EXO that it's always
positive and if so wouldn't have already
is right like I say if so again the
worry is this this natural log of 1 plus
X function is perfectly well behaved for
large X why does why does the power
series fail to converge for large X well
suppose that X is bigger than 1 then
here you get bigger and bigger powers of
X which will grow to infinity and they
grow larger they grow large faster than
the numbers 2 3 4 5 6 - they grow
exponentially and these grow just are
they and these just grow linearly so
again the general term when X is bigger
than 1 the general term will go off to
infinity even though the function that
you're talking about log of net of 1
plus X is perfectly good so the the
power series is not good outside of the
radius of convergence it's just the fact
of life yeah yeah I'd rather talk to me
after class the question is what why is
it the smaller of the two radii of
convergence and the basic answer is well
well it's well you can't expect it to be
bigger than the smaller one because we
own the power series only gives you
information inside of that range about
the function so well both in this case
both of the radii of convergence are
infinity X has radius of convergence
infinity for sure and sine of X does -
so you get infinity in that case ok ok
let's just do this and then I'm going to
integrate this and that'll be the end I
guess of what I have time for today
so what's the power series expansion for
this the power series expansion of this
is going to have be a function of T
right because the variable here is T and
I'm good I get it by taking my expansion
for e to the X and putting in what X is
in terms
T whoops and so on and so on I just put
in minus T squared in place of X there
in the series expansion for e to the X
so I can multiple work this out a little
bit better minus T squared is what it is
this is going to give me a T to the
fourth and the minus squared is going to
give me a plus so I get T to the fourth
over two factorial then I get minus T
quantity cubed so there will be a minus
sign and a T to the sixth and the
denominator is three factorial so the
signs are going to alternate the powers
are all even and the denominators are
these factorials okay
several times in the as this course has
gone on the error function has made an
appearance the error function was I
guess it gets normalized by putting a
two over the square root of Pi in front
whoops
and it's the integral of e to the minus
T squared DT from zero to X and this
normalization is here because because
that as X gets to be large value becomes
one so this is a this error function is
very important in the theory of
probability and I think you calculated
this fact at some point in the course
that's all this is the standard
definition of the error function to put
a 2 over the square root of Pi in front
let's calculate its power series
expansion so there's a 2 over the square
root of pi that hurts nobody here in the
front and now I want to integrate e to
the minus T squared and I'm going to use
this power series expansion for that
to see what you get so I'm just going to
write this out I think I did it out
carefully in another example over there
so I'll do it a little quicker now
integrate this term by term you're just
integrating powers of T so it's pretty
simple so I get and then I'm evaluating
at X and zero so I get X minus X cubed
over three plus X to the fifth over five
times two factorial 5 from integrating
the T to the fourth and the two
factorial from this denominator that we
already had and then there's a minus X
to the seventh over seven times three
factorial
and plus and so on and you can imagine
how they go on from there I guess to get
this exactly in the form that we began
talking about I should multiply through
so the coefficient of x is two over the
square root of pi and the coefficient of
x cubed is minus two over three times
the square root of pi and so on but this
is a perfectly good way to write this
power series expansion as well and this
is a very good way to compute the value
of the error function it's a new
function in in our experience your
calculator probably calculates it and
your calculator probably does it by this
method okay so that's my sermon on
examples of things you can do with power
series so we're going to do the ceg
thing in just a minute
professor jerison wanted me to make an
ad for 1802 just in case you were
thinking of not taking it next term you
really should take it it will make it'll
put a lot of things in this course into
context for one thing it's about vector
calculus and so on so you learned about
vectors and things like that but it
comes back and explains some things in
this course that might have been a
little bit strange like these strange
formulas for for the chain the product
rule and the quotient rule and they sort
of random for
millia's well one of the things you
learn in 1802 is that they're all
special cases of the chain rule and just
to drive that point home he wanted me to
to show you this poem of his that that
really drives the point home forcefully
I think